well do you remember this moment because
i do
um you helped me out so
do you remember that i do remember that
you were going to go back on stage
and this was the variety women empowered
and that was the first time we met and
you were so nice i thought
literally i was like she was so nice
she's such a girls girl i was sweaty i
just got off stage performing and i was
about to go do another thing
and i was like oh my god i'm so sweaty
and i had nothing and you totally
touched me up
um has there been another time but it's
also the indian in me i think it's a
very cultural thing to me i'll
be all up in your business and be like
let me just get you come here show me
your face
clean you up all right go on ahead it's
very it's very cultural
well it's very southern as well like
where i'm from so i thought it was
really really nice
um is there another time i'm glad you
did i did oh i loved it i'm such a
well i'm a major extrovert if you
haven't noticed so i love extroverts
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help